it was not under way yet correct it is
under way no where do we want to pick up
you know with season 2 we just want
people to continue to have fun and
continue to cry you know we're hoping
that we can branch out a little bit more
and see help more people outside of what
we help the first time and so we're just
really excited tell me what it's been
like and the impact that you've made a
being on this show of this rebirth well
you know to have people allow people to
have these cathartic moments has it been
so beautiful for me because a lot of men
especially don't know how to cry and
express themselves even when you look at
like movies with some of our favorite
celebrities they don't really cry and
bring out their tears until like force
so I like the fact that we're breaking
that down and telling them to have fun
but also check in with yourself
obviously this has been like a huge
success what's your craziest fan
experience does anyone stop to you are
they recognizing you on the streets yet
you know what's been really crazy for us
is like celebrities that have hit us up
so like Chrissy Teigen the other morning
woke up and said that she was in love
with us you know they have Chrissy
Teigen be like I'm in love with you drew
Barrymore hit us up and was like I'm
such a big fan of queer I I mean these
are people that I've looked up to
forever celebrities that are now like
I'm a fan of yours and so I just
literally every day you start to weep
and cry because I'm like these
celebrities love me so yeah ét catching
up with queer I star Kurama Brown at the
LA premiere of Chappaquiddick a new
drama based on true events
starring kate mara she is one of those
talents that you just look at and she's
old Hollywood being stunning and
gorgeous but yet she is still modern and
fresh in every role she picks you're
just like oh she's amazing
[Music]